Tu souhaites t’intéresser à la politique
mais tu n’y comprends pas grand chose?
Tu ne vois pas vraiment ce qu’est la gauche
et la droite alors qu’on en parle tout le
temps en politique?
Je m’appelle Sylvain Dramaix, je suis professeur
de sciences sociales en Belgique et dans cette
vidéo, je vais tenter de répondre à ces
questions et de t’expliquer clairement ce
qu’est la gauche et la droite en politique.
En fait, définir la gauche et la droite n’a
pas vraiment de sens. Dire ce que fait la
gauche et ce que fait la droite de manière
définitive est impossible car la gauche et
la droite en politique sont des réalités
qui ont évolué et évoluent encore aujourd’hui.
Par exemple, certaines mesures comme la nationalisation
d’entreprises c’est-à-dire le fait que
l’Etat prenne le contrôle d’une entreprise
privée était perçu comme une décision
de gauche dans la deuxième moitié du 20e
siècle mais elle est aujourd’hui considérée
comme une mesure d’extrême-gauche. Dans
le même ordre d’idée, la perception de
la gauche et de la droite peut varier d’un
pays à l’autre. Par exemple, le Mouvement
Réformateur, parti politique belge francophone,
est clairement situé à droite en Belgique
francophone mais si ce parti évoluait aux
Etats-Unis sans changer de programme, il passerait
pour un parti du centre, voire de centre-gauche.
Enfin, les représentants politiques et leur
parti peuvent également évoluer et se déplacer
sur l’échiquier politique au fil du temps.
Il faut donc bien faire attention quand on
utilise ces termes de gauche et droite car
ils n’incarnent pas une réalité fixe mais
plutôt un positionnement lié à un certain
contexte.
Cela étant dit, je vais vous donner quelques
clés pour être en mesure de dire si une
décision ou un acteur politique est plutôt
de gauche ou de droite.
Être à gauche ou à droite est un positionnement
relatif à la position d’autres acteurs
face à un enjeu. Cet enjeu peut être des
valeurs qu’il faudrait respecter. L’égalité
est une de ces valeurs qui polarise le champ
politique.
La gauche est souvent identifiée comme le
camp de celles et de ceux qui défendent l’égalité.
La personne qui considère que tous les êtres
humains sont égaux est située plus à gauche
qu’une personne qui accepterait certaines
inégalités. De ce fait, la personne située
plus à gauche sera plus facilement en faveur
de mesures qui permettent une plus grande
égalité entre les hommes et les femmes comme
par exemple un impôt sur la richesse permettant
d’aider les plus démunis.
Cependant certaines formes d’égalité sont
plus à gauche que d’autres. Une égalité
pure et simple entre les individus interdisant
toute différence de richesse serait une forme
d’égalité très à gauche. A côté de
cela, l’égalité chances qui accepte certaines
inégalités à condition que les chances
de réussite entre les individus soient les
mêmes sera perçue comme une égalité plus
acceptée à droite voire défendue par certains
hommes ou femmes politiques se présentant
clairement de droite.
Sur ce continuum des valeurs où l’égalité
forme le pôle de gauche, la droite tend vers
une autre valeur cardinale, la liberté.
Entendons-nous bien, être à gauche ou à
droite ne veut pas dire refuser la liberté
ou l’égalité mais en cas d’arbitrage
entre ces deux valeurs, chacun accordera une
importance plus grande à l’une des deux
valeurs au détriment de l’autre.
Par exemple, si l’on veut plus d’égalité
entre les individus, il faudra mettre en place
des lois qui empêchent certains comportements
discriminatoires comme les discriminations
à l’embauche) ou construire des mécanismes
de régulation comme l'impôt sur la fortune
qui réduisent en partie la liberté de chacun
en faveur d’une plus grande égalité.
Dans l’autre sens, en garantissant une liberté
plus grande aux individus comme le droit de
fixer librement des salaires dans une entreprise,
on peut créer des inégalités de richesse
pour des personnes qui exercent peut-être
le même métier.
Bref, à gauche on préfère réduire un peu
la liberté pour une plus grande égalité
tandis qu’à droite, on préfère diminuer
un peu l’égalité pour une plus grande
liberté.
Cependant, on constate parfois que des partis
dits de gauche n’agissent pas pour une plus
grande égalité et que des partis dits de
droite renient la valeur de liberté. Comment
expliquer cela?
Ce que je viens de vous dire au niveau des
valeurs de liberté et d’égalité est un
grand principe structurant mais n’est qu’un
modèle très général.
En effet, il existe différentes formes de
gauche et de droite. Et on peut très bien
être de gauche sur certains enjeux et de
droite sur d’autres. D’ailleurs, certaines
études réalisées en France montrent que
seuls ⅓ de la population est cohérente
sur tous les enjeux. En 1997, une étude du
Cevipof montrait que seulement 16% des personnes
se déclarant de gauche et 14% des personnes
se déclarant de droite étaient en accord
avec l’ensemble des positions de leur camp
sur les principales questions économiques,
sociales et sociétales.
Pour avoir une vision claire de ce que sont
la gauche et la droite, il faut bien comprendre
qu’il existe différents clivages qui structurent
le champ politique. Ces clivages évoluent
avec le temps et dans l’espace ce qui rend
parfois la politique difficilement lisible.
Je vais vous expliquer cela…
Un clivage est une division profonde et durable
de la société sur un enjeu majeur. L’opposition
gauche/droite est un clivage politique qui
est lui-même construit sur différents autres
clivages qui évoluent dans le temps. Généralement
la science politique identifie trois clivages
qui sont à la base du positionnement gauche/droite
moderne.
Le premier de ces clivages est un clivage
économique fondé sur la manière dont l’économie
doit être organisée. Faut-il que l’Etat
intervienne pour réguler plus ou moins fortement
l’économie comme le suggère les politiques
de gauche ou faut-il permettre aux entreprises
privées d’agir en toute liberté comme
le demandent les politiques de droite? Nous
pouvons nommer les deux pôles de cet axe:
intervention de l'État à gauche et liberté
économique à droite.
D’un côté, on veut plus d'État, de l’autre
plus d'initiatives pour les individus et les
entreprises privées.
Le deuxième clivage est l’opposition entre
nationalisme et humanisme universel. On sera
considéré comme plus à droite lorsque l’on
considère que le Nation auquel on appartient
est quelque chose d’important qu’il faut
défendre et qui possède une certaine identité.
A l’opposé, on sera considéré plus de
gauche si on est un défenseur de l’humanité
dans son ensemble et que l’on ne considère
que tout citoyen du monde a les mêmes droits.
Quelqu’un qui défend le droit des personnes
immigrées est donc plus à gauche que celui
qui pense que les immigrés ne peuvent pas
avoir autant de droits que les nationaux.
Le dernier clivage repose sur une conception
de l’être humain. D’un côté du continuum,
l’être humain agit en fonction de sa nature
propre. Il est donc individuellement responsable
de ses actes et doit être sanctionné en
cas de faute. La peur de la sanction empêche
les individus d’entrer en délinquance.
C’est plutôt une vision de droite.
A l’opposé, toute action humaine est considérée
comme une construction sociale. L’homme
est une éponge fortement déterminée par
son milieu et qui peut développer certaines
potentialités ou non. Les individus ne sont
donc pas toujours à 100% responsables de
ce qui leur arrive. La meilleure réponse
à certains problèmes de société reste
la prévention et l’éducation qui empêchent
les individus de commettre des actes graves.
Il s’agit là de la conception humaine propre
à la gauche.
Une réflexion identique par rapport à la
société peut également être une base du
clivage gauche/droite. Pour quelqu’un de
droite, il y a un certain ordre naturel, parfois
hérité de Dieu, un équilibre entre le bien
et le mal qui doit être maintenu pour faire
société alors que pour la personne de gauche,
toute société est une construction sociale
dans laquelle ce sont les individus eux-mêmes
qui décident ensemble comment la société
doit évoluer et donc définissent le bien
et le mal..
C’est à partir de ce dernier clivage que
des positions en faveur ou en défaveur du
mariage homosexuel, des droits LGBTQI+, de
la dépénalisation du cannabis ou de l’avortement
sont considérées de gauche ou de droite.
On peut résumer ce dernier sous-clivage à
une opposition entre progressistes et conservateurs.
Les uns souhaitent que les lois évoluent
avec la société tandis que les autres veulent
conserver les traditions.
Afin de bien fixer tout ce qui vient d’être
dit, je vous propose un tableau récapitulatif.
Vous aurez donc compris que définir la gauche
ou la droite sans aucun repère et de manière
générale est une aberration car ce sont
des réalités qui évoluent et qui ne sont
pas toujours homogènes. On est de gauche
ou de droite par rapport à un thème, par
rapport à un contexte historique et géographique
donné, par rapport à d’autres acteurs
politiques.
Etienne Schweisguth, chercheur CNRS en sciences
politiques, déclare à ce titre que :”Pour
qu’une position soit de gauche, il n’est
pas nécessaire qu’elle se situe à gauche
de manière absolue, il suffit qu’elle se
situe un peu plus à gauche que la position
de droite, et vice versa”.
Je vous remercie de votre intérêt pour ce
travail de vulgarisation et je vous dis à
très bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo de
la sociothèque.